watching AI is an important thing to do
because it's fast-moving critical
technology that's really changing a lot
of industries in quite dramatic ways
from self-driving cars to automating
business and financial services to drug
research new applications are turning up
all the time I'm a little man I'm a
senior editor for Forbes and I am
responsible for this year's AI 50 list
of companies to watch the list is
looking at America's most promising
artificial intelligence companies this
is tech that is going to be with us for
a long time and become deeper and more
meaningful this list highlights 50 of
the top a AI companies in the United
States all the companies on this list
are privately held not publicly traded
Sequoia uses a proprietary algorithm to
narrow hundreds of applicants into a top
100 candidates then Forbes works with a
group of industry leading experts to
determine the 50 that made the list
you're not to see so I encourage you as
you're reading the list to really think
about what problem is this AI company
solving for people most cases many of
the companies made a point of noting
that they're trying to create better
tools for employees which ideally saves
companies money and allows employees to
do their jobs more efficiently ideally
that should also mean that customers are
much happier the first thing that we
always remember is that AI is not magic
in fact it's a decades-long continuation
of the computation revolution really AI
is a computational application of
statistics at its core AI is about
making informed decisions
ai makes probabilistic suggestions based
on data for example AI can use data to
predict the likelihood of something
being true or optimal to put it simply
if you can quantify the goal you can
train an AI to optimize towards that
goal we are seeing increasing focus on
using AI to enhance business services
and employee functions but not
necessarily replacing human workers vis
I on the list significantly reduces the
time to diagnose a stroke that's
particularly important because in a
stroke you lose 1.9 million cells per
per minute ai can also make your
decision-making more accurate for
example data profit on the list uses AI
to reduce error rates in factories in
the autonomous vehicle space company
like neuro for example really looks very
interesting this year neuro is not
developing robotic taxi services and
self-driving vehicles for to carry
humans around that instead street-legal
robotic vehicles that are purely
designed for delivery of goods I think
an important trend or takeaway from this
list is the vast ways in which AI is now
becoming part of our daily lives and is
being integrated in
every imaginable type of company service
and in most cases many of the companies
we talked to and as information we
reviewed make a point that they're not
trying to eliminate human workers the
goal is better tools help people do
their jobs better more efficiently which
benefits companies bottom lines and
ideally makes customers a lot happier
[Music]